- Vegan barbecue.
- Oh.
- So today we're gonna
be trying vegan barbecue.
I am from a barbecue town.
She is from opposing barbecue like
this is something that
they pretend that they do.
- I'm from Memphis, Tennessee,
and we obviously have the better barbecue.
- How do you have your meats?
- Oh a medium well.
- Medium rare is the way to go.
- I'm excited.
I'm interested to see
what this tastes like.
I've learned just get the (beeps) food.
(laughs)
- It looks like Sloppy Joe to me.
- It does.
- It smells like barbecue is (beeps).
- Low key excited about this.
- Hmm.
This is (beeps) good.
- Why is this a trick?
- No, this is good.
- Yeah, this is good.
Is this meat?
- What is it?
- We're eating mushrooms?
I hate mushrooms.
- This shit is good.
Oh my God.
I'm gonna keep eating it though.
Bring on the next one.
- Cheers corn dog.
Cheers.
- When you eat this you
know there isn't meat in it.
- It tastes like a hot dog,
but the texture is (beeps) up.
- This is not for me.
This is not of God.
God wanted us to have hot dogs.
- It's weird 'cause it
has no real taste, right?
- But if Beyonce was in
one of her vegan phase --
- If Beyonce was like do you
want a hot dog, absolutely.
- Yes, several.
I'm starving sis.
Please give me multiple.
- Why ribs like why you gotta try for
like the number one dish?
- Oh hell no.
Don't. (laughs)
Nope. (laughs)
- It tastes like corn bread
that is like not sweet.
- [Nyla] Not today Satan.
- I truly don't taste anything.
I'm honestly not that mad at it.
- Someone who's trying
to cut back on meat,
I would definitely look
into some of these options.
- I feel like this is not
gonna make me go digging
in anyway, but I will eat
that vegan pulled pork again.
- Like I would totally go vegan,
but I would stay away from the hot dog.
- Yeah, vegan food is good.
You could find some
really good vegan stuff,
and then you could find
some really nasty stuff.
It's just like meat.
- It is just like meat, you know?
Find some good meat, bad meat.
- You know who you are.
(laughs)
(country music)